[Musica]
Noi siamo il team dei lupi mannari il
lupi mannari proprio come nel mio nuovo
libro La città stregata in cui c'è un
nuovo mistero da risolvere perfetto per
il periodo di Halloween in più dentro
c'è anche un alfabeto segreto in cui
potrete tradurre tutti i nostri messaggi
segreti Anzi Ecco qua per voi un
messaggio segreto con il libro potrete
tradurlo se ancora non ce l'avete andate
subito a prenderlo in libreria o on
Questi sono i miei amici lupi lupo lex
già lo conoscete e lei è Lexi la sorella
di lupo lex Esatto lei è la mia
sorellina e infatti ci assomigliamo
tantissimo Guardate gli occhi ce li
abbiamo di colori
diversi Wow Guarda luce che se mamma mia
Ciao io sono Veruska la leader dei
vampiri e loro sono Vitale Ciao Conte
francola Sì sì
eh puoi stare zitto eh ma ancora non ho
manco parlato ho detto quasi niente hai
rovinato la presentazione e che cosa
dovevo fare dovevo presentarvi Ciao Sono
Vitale sto qua perché basta Vitale Scusa
se adesso e poi starò sempre zitto te lo
giuro grazie Chi vincerà questa
Challenge vincerà il nuovo libro La
città stregata perché questo libro ha un
potere che tutti vogliono e cioè dentro
all'alfabeto Segreto e con l'alfabeto
segreto si possono tradurre i messaggi
segreti e questo darà un vantaggio a
chiunque vincerà nelle prossime
Challenge e darà un vantaggio anche a
voi perché voi potrete tradurre i
messaggi segreti che ci saranno nei
video in anticipo e scoprire i vari
indizi Quindi siete pronti brusca
prendiamolo prendiamolo subito Ahia
iniziamo subito la Challenge
[Musica]
vi
per la prima Challenge dovremo
affrontarci in una Challenge di velocità
il primo che arriverà al traguardo
vincerà la Challenge vediamo ora se
vinceranno i
vampiri o i lupi Se fate parte del team
dei lupi lasciate un commento bene Ora
mi riscaldo perché tanto lo sappiamo
tutti che vincerà questa lupetta
qui Sì sì Ti piacerebbe Io sono un
vampiro posso sbattere le ali e arrivare
più veloce al vento subito subitissimo
Anzi sono pronto 3 2 1
[Musica]
via il sole non si possa credere il sole
mi fa male gli occhi mi fa male la vista
non ce la faccio non arriverò mai
[Musica]
Sì ho vinto Ho
vinto Ho
vinto Come avete visto noi vampiri
abbiamo un problemino con la luce del
sole ma io ho un piano per
vincere tocca a me Ho un po' di paura
dei
[Musica]
vampiri Ehi lex sì che
c'è lo sapevo che avrebbe
funzionato
finito ho vinto è stato così facile
bastava soltanto utilizzare l'ingegno
contro questi stupidi lupi mannari Ah
l'X è sempre il solito
fifone Sì mio fratello sempre stato così
fifone Insomma si è fatto battere da
quella vampirella uscita da Hotel
Transylvania
già Ehi ma tocca a me vai
Presto Userò la stessa tecnica di
Veruska Perché si ha funzionato con lei
sicuro funzionerà anche con me e
vinceremo noi il libro sono prontissima
vinceremo noi il libro La città
stregata Ehi non V è partito
prima tanto lo batto lo stesso Ah il
sole
Anita che
c'è sono troppo allergico al
sole Sì ce l'ho fatta i lupi hanno vinto
questa prima Challenge ma ora passiamo
alla seconda
via per questa seconda Challenge dovremo
giocare a nascondino i primi a
nascondersi saranno i lupi vanari pronti
è che vinc il migliore e cioè
noi abbiamo trovato una soluzione per
noi vampiri occhiali da
sole
perché eh metti che ne perdo uno almeno
c'ho quello de riserva no Quanto sei
stupido Vitale Ah ma io non so dove
nascondermi dove posso nascondere dietro
un albero in mezzo a un cespuglio sotto
una pietra Non lo so dove posso Ciao
sono l'emoji di Anita sono qua per
ricordarvi che è appena uscito oggi il
mio nuovo libro La città
stregata Se non ce l'avete Ancora andate
subito a prenderlo perché i primi che lo
prenderanno riceveranno in regalo il
poster con me e Merlino autografato da
me con dietro l'alfabeto segreto con cui
condivideremo tanti messaggi assieme
prendetelo
subito dove saranno finiti qui Maledetti
cagnacci ma da qua sul terrazzo riuscirò
a vedere ogni
nascondiglio
[Musica]
Sono nascosto bene qui ma quello
è l'ex sta provando a nascondersi adesso
G faccio prendere un
colpo Speriamo che nessuno mi
veda ah
Aiuto
aiuto Guardate questo cespuglio gigante
è Il nascondiglio perfetto per
nasconderci dai vampiri vero Sì non ci
troveranno mai
andiamo Non ci posso credere setto odore
di
mela e Eh sì effettivamente sono delle
mele queste Aspetta Sento anche odore di
lupo lupaccio bagnato puzza di pelo di
lupo Dove
[Musica]
saranno Eppure Sento puzza di
lupo ho girato due volte non c'è niente
Sarà dall'altra
parte che stupido quel vampiro è
stupidissimo È passato troppo tempo e
ancora non c'è traccia dei lupi Vitale
ma cosa stai
facendo Sto giocando con la palla no
scrivete Vitale Ma tu sei un genio
grazie
modestamente molti mi definiscono un
genio questa non è una palla Eh no
Questa è la luna piena Sì la luna piena
e sai che cosa tra i
lupi la carne no Vitale la luna piena Ah
non ci avevo pensato che stupido così i
lupi saranno attratti dalla luna piena e
vinceremo la sfida perché li troveremo
Sei un genio Verusca lo so grazie È il
momento Ragazzi quando io alzerò la luna
i lupi mannari saranno attratti e
verranno qui che bello Vai
[Musica]
ti abbiamo
trovati abbiamo vinto Sì era una
trappola la luna piena non è giusto
avete usato
un nostro punto debole per atar qua
Ebbene sì e abbiamo anche vinto il
libro ha di Conte
fancula non è giusto questo È
imbrogliare e no cara lupacchiotta
perché anche voi avete utilizzato a
vostro favore un nostro punto debole
Ovvero la luce del sole e si sa che noi
vampiri non possiamo esporci Sì ma poi
comunque voi avete trovato la soluzione
noi non abbiamo nulla per proteggerci
dalla luna invece voi avete gli occhiali
da sole infatti bl bl bla Tanto voi
aveste perso lo stesso perché uno di voi
alla mia vista è scappato già Eh sì è
proprio così lupo lex è
scappato fifone come vi permettete a
parlare così di mio fratello Infatti E
poi se la mettete così nell'utilizzare
il nostro punto debole allora anche noi
utilizzeremo un vostro Altro punto
debole Infatti voi ne avete due e noi
solo uno No in realtà noi ne abbiamo
anche un E vabbè comunque Beccatevi
queste
quello
cipolla Ma sei cretino Sì è
aglio
agoo
[Musica]
aiuto
divertente
guardali sono stupidi ben vista così
imparate Non ci resta che andare a
prendere il libro presto sì noi lupi
abbiamo vinto la Challenge e il libro La
città stregata d'ora in poi potremo
tradurre tutti i messaggi segreti con
l'alfabeto Segreto e se non ce l'avete
ancora correte a prenderlo in libreria
oppure onl
Ciao
[Musica]
a